so when it came to my protein you tell
the story in a very interesting way in
the book um about how you first had the
idea i wonder obviously we'll put a link
to the in to the book in the video
description but for the people who
aren't familiar with the story sure how
did you have the idea to start a
powdered protein brand that's
pretty it's pretty random it is random
however saying that it wasn't random for
me because i was a user of the products
obviously not my protein but i was a
user of maximosel which was the leading
product
in in uk at the time it was a retail
product so maxim muscle was effectively
the the sports nutrition go-to brand um
in the uk
i so rolling back slightly i was in i
was i was into fitness
um and i was since i was around 16 17
and as you progress through the fitness
fitness chain you then got into the um
the nutrition side of it and and again
as part of the nutrition chain you then
find the supplement side because you
can't get enough nutrition from food
as you need to to maximize your gains
and i was a bodybuilder if you like back
there not no
i enjoyed myself on a weekend too much
so i wasn't fully strict
but back then it was uh but certainly
monday to friday i was very very
anal if i can say that very precise on
my what trained or what the weight and
so
naturally through that supplements
become part and parcel of the everyday
life of a bodybuilder so i was using a
mac product by maxine mussel a whey
protein product and it was it was just a
eureka moment as the chapter in the book
says and it's
and i did this systematically with
probably 100 plus products before i did
it with the protein products i it was a
positive habit i had where i broke it
down i tried to see if i could do it
better
i knew i believed in myself i believed
in
my web skills and i believed i wanted to
put and i believed in the web itself
this was 2002 2003. i believe that i put
a product on online vertically
integrated it was its own brand it had
the right economics behind it i could
sell it i believed in myself to do that
um
so so i i the positive habit i had was
to actually break the product down and
one day i was sat in my
my kitchen my mum's kitchen of actually
and i was making my bedtime shake i
think it was a thursday night and i can
remember it vividly and i said what is
actually what a protein and it just sort
of came to me because i did it
systematically as i said um and it looks
on the back of the ingredients it says
whey protein flavoring sweetener
and some of her fillers and vitamins and
whatnot and then i didn't actually know
what whey protein was um i don't know if
i was i'm alone on that but back then it
was actually a byproduct not many years
before maybe a decade before that was
being thrown away
um no put intended so whey protein is
effectively
no protein is actually a byproduct
cheese so when you make cheese you then
the cheese floats the top and the the
liquid at the bottom is whey weighs and
kurds as the nursery rhyme says so if
you someone once found out that the the
whey protein is very very high in
protein
and if you filter it enough it becomes a
highly bioavailable source of protein
it's used in baby foods and of course
whey protein powder for sports nutrition
after doing that research then i found
uh i thought okay that's interesting i
wonder where you get away from so i
found some dairies who make cheese
i went through the cycle of asking lots
and lots of them but in short i found
out it was three pounds a kilo to buy
whey protein the raw material
and then um yeah i did my maths
basically whey protein with flavoring
sweeteners i could make the product for
about five six pounds a kilo and it has
been sold retail for about 30 pounds for
two pounds which is
um which is just less than a kilo wow
908 grams yeah
so so i thought there's some margin in
that okay so maxi muscle and stuff they
were already selling whey protein
correct and so it's not like you
reinvented the wheel by just suddenly
discovering whey protein was a thing it
was more like hang on i can do this
better and i can do it cheaper and i can
go direct to consumer absolutely so the
the obviously the key the key angle the
the key usps which are obviously
absolutely essential when everyone says
oh i've got a new business what is your
usp it's you know it's fundamentally if
you have multiple usps better so look
there's people selling whey protein i'm
not trying to profess i invented whey
protein absolutely not this was done for
maybe maybe five six seven years before
and in america for longer
but what no one was doing was do selling
it online as a brand a vertically
integrated brand so i own calta customer
so so effectively straight from the
dairy uh into onto our plan we we
blended it it wasn't a big manufacturing
process there's more blending powders
adding flavorings and then we sold it
direct to the consumer we did all the
fulfillment and then all of the
aftercare customer service yeah that's
right that would have been quite like
trailblazing in back in 2002 where you
know
accepting payments on the internet
only became
trivial in like 2012 when stripe came
along
so
how did you go about building
all of that in the days where we didn't
have wordpress and shopify and
woocommerce and all the other stuff yeah
look obviously that was a big barrier
entry to be honest and i was fortunate
enough that i've come from a tech
background a personally a self-trained
uh tech background
um but my i was i i actually when i left
school at 16 i had a year of
milling around doing not very much
productive and then i had a wake-up call
time to get
you're asking gay if i can say that and
um
the the what jumped out to me i tried
the academic study route ali but it was
it wasn't for me i was
i don't know i don't learn that way and
i believe that's a behavioral um
a behavioral thing a a learning
disability in some some way for me it's
not how i learn i learn very much on on
the job so i tried i didn't do very well
at school i got one gcse
um and it wasn't through lack of lack of
care it was through lack of focus and
like it wasn't engaging with me so
that's something i really want to try
and champion at some point in the future
because i think there's not one way to
skin a cat in terms of uh in terms of
education secondly i tried um college
but i knew i went did it college but i i
don't want to sound big-headed or cocky
here but i i said to the teacher look i
believe i know this can i go into the
the the higher class the higher form
there's two there's lower and upper i.t
he says no you're not good enough you're
in lower but i before that i'd been
building computers from ground up and
doing working with um working computers
as well so i knew everything i wasn't so
just said this is a waste of my time and
one thing i hate doing is wasting time
so i left college had the year of
milling around and then i walked past a
back then there was shop fronts with
modern apprenticeship
opportunities which i'm not sure they
still did on apprenticeships these days
it's effectively working within a
company where um
where you learn on a job but do a day at
college every week so it's like i need
to come out of an nvq level three which
is equivalent to an a level
so i i went right this is computer
development junior programmer working
for a company making ide drivers which
basically make industrial machines talk
to each other which is probably the most
boring thing you can develop in the
world but i went there i went in at 16
or 17 and i was making i was doing the
photocopying doing um making cups of tea
and doing all of the all the things you
expected june apprentice to do what i
did learn there which was absolutely key
was the dynamics of office politics
and that is so so important so i learned
how different people engage with each
other and what that what's expected and
just the way the the the dynamics of an
office flow
it taught me so much and then i learned
how to start developing there more
professionally and that is when someone
introduced me to the world wide web
and then my mind was blown so from from
then which is about 97 i was starting to
i bought a book of how to make websites
and i literally told myself pearl i
think the language was javascript html
and later java
and then finally called fusion and my
sequel um
and but websites so i was building
websites for five seven years before i
started my protein in 2003. i worked in
bbc jessups.com on quite a few of our
websites